I think now the client of class
I was reading I think I interview you
did with the root on
if you give some opinions on occupy wall
street and I was thinking now and
especially just listening to Bob Herbert
he was saying how all these movements
accomplished a lot but they ultimately
flamed out and in and wanting to start
maybe a more sustainable movement how
what do you think is like the first
thing or what are some of the things
that we should really focus on I think
if you really look at the way which
justice is administered you'd find that
the first thing was really in need of
repair everybody needs a job we should
have work and you know fair wages and
fair employment and all that stuff but
there's an underlying essence that's a
hardly ever discussed and it's justice
because it is how justice reveals itself
in the midst of these efforts that
ultimately tells you what kind of course
were you on it is mind-boggling to me
that they should have met Ben men with
great power who stole the National
Treasury in the tune of trillions of
dollars that cannot be found that cannot
be reclaimed and when it came time to
look at justice and how to stop this in
sanity those who repaired the moment
left the very same people who did all
this mischief in the same seats of power
and decision-making without any any
discussion or debate and answers to the
to the nation how is it possible that we
could still be sitting here having
decisions made at this very moment by
the very same people who stole the
Treasury just yesterday and were the
same thugs the same villains the same
corrupt forces how do they how do they
prevail and what is it in the public
discourse and the protection of public
policy that makes us all capitulate to
that to let us accept it where's the
protest where's the resistance who is
this a hold on you guys can't go any
further let's discuss this problem
because they're preparing for your next
demise
they haven't changed at all what you're
looking at is what they think what the
mistakes they made and now they're
fixing its of those mistakes will not be
repeated you'll create new ones and how
do they do that you've got a Supreme
Court that's locked against justice it's
of court that's luck to an ideology and
that ideology is undermined justice all
the way so if you change the checks and
balances that were created by the
founding fathers in order to keep the
machine of government active and and
creative and thinking and protecting the
populace and once that that's dissolve
you get the Congress now the Republicans
control the house they're on their way
to try to control the Senate those to
which were watchdogs for each other now
become one ideology they wrap up with
the executive branch because the the
President of the United States has not
used this bully pulpit to move justice
alone he's been politically fanciful
always manipulated the system from a
political but the villainy still
prevails how do you challenge that how
do you make it not so and I think all
these things are being ignored or people
are being distracted but if you don't
look at what happens to justice if you
look at Homeland Security the law that
is the law of the land any one of us
sitting in this room could leave this
room or not even leave the room two guys
can walk in here in it command any one
of you overwhelm you take you out to a
car whisk you away and the world will
never hear from you again by the
approval of law you don't get charged
because they don't have to charge you
with a crime don't have to tell you what
you did you have no right to a lawyer
you have no right to one phone call
absolutely nothing and the law says we
can do that and that law was passed and
when Barack Obama became the prelate of
the United States he inherited that law
and in this campaign he denounced that
law so my problem with him doesn't know
whether
he gave a bank seven hundred billion
dollars or not my problem with him is
where is your moral Center where is your
line how can you look at this does this
injustice that prevails as part of the
law of the land with your powers the
presidency to change it you don't need
the Congress to change it ultimately you
do but certainly in these early stages
you could with the stroke of executive
order on a pen change some of this
challenge some of it awaken the public
to the fact that these law but he
doesn't do that so we sit in this moral
vacuum you sit in a place where nobody
leads us to the higher order or to the
greater truth so we Syria dealing with
all these things in the sub issues in
these subterranean ways we're busy
watching what's in the mousetrap well
somebody else is running off of the
entire wedge of trees